we have to give a shout out to New York
Times our sponsors especially after this
article you read I'm sure you guys going
to be buying their magazine uh I'm I'm
convinced you're going to be subscribing
to them and reading every article of
theirs because when I read this I'm like
what like the level of stuff they write
I mean you think this is a joke okay
here's New York Times there has never
been a better time to be short okay so
this article goes down keep going down
and it says how it is bad you know
something from where I stand at five
feet seven being tall is widely held
fantasy Superior in Arizona it made
sense a fun overhype when facility ages
ago when necessary is defending yourself
if you go all the way to the bottom and
read this article you know what it's
really saying how tall people should
stop having kids okay how sure it's
shorter people are better for society
why we should go back to being short and
not being taller why it's not fair I
mean
the average person who has logic who
reads this says who even approved this
opinion to be written with the Brand New
York Times unless if you're just trying
to get a lot of eyeballs for people to
talk about it okay what do you see with
the level of credibility New York Times
has today
I know you're a big fan of this I know
you're like a big spokesperson for them
going around always trying to get people
to subscribe I mean I I'm just I'm
endlessly shocked and disappointed by
the New York Times and you know in the
Washington Post too and really all of
the mainstream media but the question is
why is this you know project Mockingbird
just simply one or is this the breakdown
incompetence having produced a newspaper
that you know wouldn't know news if it
hit it in the face it's or would you
secretly fantasize about owning them
the New York Times I I never fantasize
about owning the New York Times no you
wouldn't want to be like the
editor-in-chief or I think they've done
too much damage to the brand for it to
be anything other than funny
but what's your level of certainty
though 100 97 where are you at on us
that it would be good on the New York
Times I'm at three percent I believe a
margin of error yeah
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
thank you
[Music]